so I promised two kinds of
transformation right I promised one side
of UT the other one starts with D now
this is a bit of a funny interesting
word it's actually been introduced in
the new syllabus and so I'm going to use
it and I'm going to give you some
synonyms for it that word is dilation so
when we think about translation we're
thinking about the graph staying exactly
the same size but then shuffling around
in different places the scale remains
unchanged but when we think about
dilation I don't know how many of you
have had to go to like an
ophthalmologist or a North Optus then
had your eyes dilated right when you go
into a dark room and of course your
pupils get bigger so you can see better
you can absorb more light that's the
same idea here right we're thinking
about changing the scale of the graph
they're getting bigger and smaller and
just like with translation we're going
to think about it first horizontally and
then vertically okay so have a look at
this guy now what I've got provided for
you here is a big set Act he's wearing
drawn here in a second but just like
with our translation we're going to
explore this with technology first so
I'm showing you these two equations so
that you can take the time to put them
into desmos as I've written them here y
equals x minus 1 or squared it's a
parabola and it's been moved over one
unit to the right or excuse me the axes
have moved one unit to the left and then
you've got this other one over here y
equals x on a minus 1 all the rest ok so
let's take a moment to put this into
desmos together who made this big C you
can see it there I'm gonna move this a
back to one because that's where it
defaulted and let's put some brackets in
here so that we can adjust things as
necessary minus one and then I'm gonna
adjust this guy over here on the left
right hand side okay so in my bracket
divided by hey and then I've got minus
one okay
so I'm going to get rid of my working
over here on the left now because you
can see the equations of the graphs just
in my desmos window so I hope they're
clear up there in the top left now what
are we looking at at this exact moment
well if your screen looks I did
to call to mine with the same value of a
the default where it's not equals one
then my red graph and my blue graph are
exactly the same graph do you see that
because I've got X divided by 1 X on 1
so that's just X right so I've got X
minus 1 squared and then I've got X
minus 1 squared again okay now I want
you to think about what's gonna happen
when we change this value of a where are
things going to move now I'm just going
to put one value in there and then we're
gonna start drawing all over this thing
okay if I say move a onto two hmm what
difference have we got here now I kind
of I slightly gave away the game by
telling you what this thing was called
but I hope you still have some thinking
to do here right there's a dilation a
change I like to actually use the word
stretch because you can in fact when you
go back put a back to one and then
literally watch the graph as you change
from 1 all the way up to 2 you can see
you're kind of stretching it out like a
piece of toffee right it's now much
wider than what I started with so what
what way can I explain what's actually
happening here
well not everything has changed right
some things have actually remained the
same the red and the blue graph share a
couple of points that are actually
identical and the one that I'm most
interested in I'm going to take a
screenshot so I can draw on him the one
I'm most interested in the one that
actually hasn't gone anywhere is if I
got a suitable color here let's try um
let's try green it's this point right in
here wow that's really thin let's try
something a bit bigger mmm that's really
thin how do I make this thicker hmm I'm
just gonna leave it let's undo that one
I don't need that squiggle okay now you
can see in here right this x intercept
think about it carefully sorry we're not
x intercept this y-intercept hasn't gone
anywhere the y-intercept has remained
unchanged and what I like to do is on
desmos go ahead change a to any value
like and as you see this thing
stretching and squashing you will see
this y-intercept stays put doesn't go
anywhere okay but every other value on
the graph moves or it stretches out it
dilates right let's have a look at some
of these spots in particular memo trade
route
black that might be more useful okay
let's have a look at the x-intercept for
example the accept x-intercept used to
be at one there it is right in there I'm
using a pencil that's weird no that's
why I didn't want that let's try
something like this okay
there's x equals one right there and
where's the new x-intercept appeared
well it's stretched all the way over to
two there it is right now
I haven't think about that for a second
the x-intercept was one and now it's
shifted over so I shifted I should say
stretched it's stretched all the way
over to two well there's one value pick
another one let's have a look for
example on my graph whoopsie-daisy I
want to zoom out all the way on my graph
one of the other spots that happens to
land on some whole numbers is here at x
equals two on my original graph and y
equals 1 that's 2 comma 1 over there ok
now this point here it it is also
stretched right it's stretched over all
the way to this spot over here where is
it well again you can see it on the
coordinate axes right here it's out 4
comma 1 so what am i doing here I'm
comparing the same y-value I'm looking
across there but I noticed that my X
values have all doubled do you see that
I mean it works for everything even the
ones that aren't on like a nice neat
spot let's have a look at something like
say this spot here right what is that in
horizontal terms well that looks to me
like it's around x equals I'm gonna call
that 1.78 or something like that right
well where is that gone to where is its
equivalent point that moved that's
stretched over to the right hand side
what's gone all the way over here right
in fact I'm just gonna draw a straight
line all the way through it with my undo
go there it is it's just gonna go all
the way over there to the right hand
side and predictably
that value has doubled it's it's looking
like it's around x equals 3.5 whatever
right and you can do this for every
single point it goes over to the it goes
over to the negative side as well if you
pick a spot like this it's gone twice as
far horizontally
stretched-out but this time it's in the
negative direction because your original
value was also negative okay so so what
are we seeing here right I'm going to
say done let's get rid of this okay what
I'm getting is if I have and now I'm
ready to if you've been just playing
around in desmos like I have it's become
time to come back to your piece of paper
so we can draw this together if I have a
graph like this parabola here and I'll
call this my original y equals x minus 1
or squared then my new graph and let's
uh let's choose a different color for it
so let's call this guy green my new
graph is going to look just like this
but it has been dilated or stretched
horizontally and just like we saw with
translation we should have expected that
it was a horizontal change because look
at where this a which is the thing that
we're using to change look at where it's
attached it's attached to the x value
which is about horizontal change okay so
therefore I'm going to do my best to
draw a new fatter version of the graph
like so so you can see this has been
stretched out I'm gonna fix that up
because I've missed my my y intercept
there that's better
so this is the one and only spot the y
intercept there which doesn't move
anywhere because it's right there in the
middle so when you stretch it out a it
stays where it is but everything else
you know and we move from x equals 1 to
x equals whoops I went too far
to x equals 2 when we were having a look
at our X intercepts right and any other
point you can take it stretches and
dilates in that dimension okay let me
pause there I'm kind of sick to death of
my own voice and I want you to have a
think about this yourself if this is
what dilation looks like when I attach
this division or multiplication to the x
value well what would you expect when
you attach the the divisional
multiplication of a to the Y value this
is a whole different set of graphs there
I invite you to go into desmos draw
these two and then have a look at one
graph these two on the on the software
and then how to think about drawing them
and how you would explain what's
happening differently how would you
articulate the kind of dial
it's happening there okay I know graphs
take time and I want you to take the
time to explore it a bit on desmos so
I'm looking at the time now I've got ten
twelve so I'm gonna give you three
minutes to have a bit of a play and
you're welcome as well like we're
looking at a parabola because we're
familiar with parabolas but you're
welcome to put in some other kind of
function too like a cubic or something
more exotic have a fiddle and then we'll
come back in a few minutes to look at
the results together okay and you're
welcome to ask questions in the chat if
you have any okay so after you've asked
the question why does the equation look
like with Y as the subject and this is
an interesting exercise that I'd love
you to have a fiddle with right if we
want Y as the subject I can do this for
the both equations right for this guy
here y plus 1 equals x squared is a
pretty simple operation I can do to both
sides so you probably already worked
that out that's why you're asking about
the green one so I'm going to subtract 1
from both sides if I do that over here
what's what's that going to look like
well if I take this green thing here
I'll start off in the same way just get
some space up here I'm gonna add 1 to
both sides so I started to detract one I
should say Y on a equals x squared minus
1 and then I think about what you want
to do make a the subject I'm gonna
multiply both sides by a so that gives
me a outside of x squared minus sorry 1
I was expanding and factorizing the same
time my brain so this is what it would
look like with Y as a subject but I hope
it becomes clear to you that this if I
write it with Y as a subject it doesn't
make it as clear that the a is the way I
think about it it's really acting on Y
it's not acting on X even though it's
written there on the right hand side
what's it really fiddling with if you've
had a go at desmos you'll see it's not
about our horizontal change so much as
it's about a vertical change at least
that's the way we've conceptualized it
here okay so I'm looking the time and
we've we always go away every time so
let's to quickly fiddle with this ok and
when you change air you see what's
happening here right this is this is
also stretching and dilating but it's
stretching and dilating up and down so
as an example if I pick the nice
convenient value like say 3 you can see
my previous y-intercept there was
why equals negative one and it's been
stretched out vertically so now it's y
equals negative three and you can pick
out any other point and notice that same
kind of I've moved three times further
away relationship so I'm just going to
quickly draw these onto here so I've
getting a parabola that's been moved
downward like I said mm-hmm not my best
work but I'm just gonna keep moving just
for the sake of time and then you can
see what I've got here is this vertical
stretch so it's gonna look something
like this there are these points that
stay the same
but it's the it's the x-intercepts these
times because they're right on the x
axis they haven't moved up or down okay
they're at y equals zero as it were
alright so this is the one that I've
gotten I kind of run a ran out of time
to do the rest of the detail so let me
actually do that now since we're we're
looking at it okay what have I got here
well remember our original graph over
here y plus y equals x squared I put
that in blue so let me put a bit more
detail on there now I can work out if I
do a bit of rearrangement algebraically
I can very quickly show myself where all
the intercepts are so for example if I
put over if I subtract one from both
sides and write this is x squared minus
one I can do a little factorization here
using difference of squares and that
tells me my positive and negative
x-intercepts so that'll be negative I'm
sorry that we positive one rather and
that one over there will be negative one
at the same time I can work out my y
intercept which is going to be negative
one I knew that from the outset because
I started at the origin and then I
translated downwards one unit so that's
what the blue graph looks like and the
green graph has everything the blue
graph has but it's being stretched out
vertically by a factor of a because I'm
doing this is the general case here
right so if my intercept used to be
negative one my sorry my y intercept I
should say if I y intercept used to be
negative one well my y intercept will
now be negative a it's a times further
away and any spot that you pick for
example let's pick a spot like here um
actually I'll go over a little
more so that I can actually go to X
equals 2 if I put in X equals 2 into the
original graph the blue one right I'm
going to get y plus 1 equals 2 squared
there's me substituting in x equals 2 so
y plus 1 equals 4 so Y is going to be
equal to 3 so I would say oh that's 2
comma 3 so now if I were to search for
where the equivalent point was on the
green graph I would know that if I put
in the same x value I'll get a y value
but it'll be a times further away so
that would be all the way up here
somewhere up up in this spot up here it
would be 2 comma 3 a so just like this y
intercept is a times further away this
corner here and in fact every single
coordinate is a times further away in a
vertical direction and it's vertical
because of course we're actually
fiddling with the Y which is a vertical
variable okay